[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis zweiter weihnachtstag herzlich
willkommen trotz des feiertags gab sport
was passiert ist erfahren sie von sap
fonds auch um ihren schirm und die
großen themen heute
im ziel der regierung erreicht mehr als
30 millionen zusätzliche dosen wurden
seit november 15.000 auch jetzt an
weihnachten
trauer um das gewissen südafrikas
desmond tutu anti apartheids kämpfer und
friedensnobelpreisträger ist gestorben
und
paradies in gefahr auf den seychellen
kämpfen die menschen gegen die folgen
der klimakrise und um jeden zentimeter
lang
angesichts der besonders ansteckenden
omikron variante versuchen bund und
länder die impfkampagne voranzubringen
seit genau einem jahr wird jetzt in
deutschland gegen korona gift und den
anfang machte edith kurz ahler am 26
dezember 2020 bekam die damals 101
jährige die allererste spritze millionen
menschen in deutschland wurden seitdem
geimpft in den letzten wochen zieht das
tempo wieder merklich an bis jahresende
30 millionen zusätzliche impfung dieses
ziel wurde jetzt erreicht ein anderes
jedoch nicht bis siebten januar sollten
80 prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sein
damit wird es aber noch dauern
heike kruse berichtet aus einem
impfzentrum
lübeck im weihnachts glanz minus sechs
grad sind es heute morgen aber die
schlange ist lang und die motivation der
impfwilligen hoch sehr hoch
wir machen hier noch keine vierte
trotzdem einen schönen tag mehr als 80
prozent der wartenden sind für die
dritte die auffrischungsimpfung da
weihnachten hin oder her die impfung ist
uns sehr wichtig und wir sind froh dass
er noch einen termin bekommen haben ich
habe erst
komme ich jetzt zum bußtag
und das war schön und hat auch einen
spaziergang machen wie mehr als 85
prozent der erwachsenen in der region
lübeck ist auch karl heinz trug bereits
zweifach geimpft die landesregierung
schleswig-holstein will mit dem
weihnachts impfen das signal geben keine
feiertagspause im kampf gegen das virus
probleme bei der impfstoff lieferung
habe es in lübeck bislang nicht gegeben
aus meiner sicht sowohl in meiner
eigenen praxis als auch im zentrum hat
mir immer genug impfstoff und zwar von
allen von allen firmen wir haben täglich
acht bis 900 impfung hier in diesem im
zentrum und das ist schon gebucht bis
anfang januar bis mitte januar
sowie in lübeck wird an vielen orten in
deutschland auch zwischen den jahren
geimpft mit oder ohne anmeldung
die aktuellen infektionszahlen sind
nicht verlässlich da den feiertagen
weniger getestet und gemeldet wird das
robert koch institut registrierte
10.100 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages
19.000 248 weniger als vergangenen
sonntag
88 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kobe 19 die sieben tage incidents ist
auf
220,7 gesunken
von deutschland werden wir jetzt unseren
blick in den gaza streifen und schauen
wie die korona lage dort ist der
gazastreifen ist ja einer der am
dichtesten besiedelten orte der welt
abgeriegelt durch israel wo die omikron
fälle gerade sprunghaft zunehmen fast
zwei millionen menschen leben im
gazastreifen nur eine halbe million von
ihnen sind geimpft und auch dort wurde
heute die omikron variante des corona
virus nachgewiesen
man werde alles unternehmen um die
ausbreitung der neuen variante
einzudämmen sagt das
gesundheitsministerium und für uns vor
ort in gaza stadt ist anna weiß tanna
wie es der gaza-streifen aufgestellt im
kampf gegen die kunden
ja es ist fast als würde corona hier gar
nicht existieren schaut man sich um im
öffentlichen leben so tragen weder die
lokale bevölkerung noch militärs oder
polizisten eine maske oder halten gar
sicherheitsabstand dabei hat erst heute
die radikal islamistische hamas
verkündet dass am nikon nur oft nun
offiziell hier angekommen sei wir haben
heute mittag in einem krankenhaus
gedreht auf einer kuh wird 19 stationen
und dort trugen weder die ärzte noch das
personal noch die angehörigen ffp zwei
masten oder gar schutzausrüstung im
umgang mit coop 19 patienten ein mann
dessen ungeimpfte mutter auf dieser
kowitz station lag hat uns erzählt dass
er in seiner von mir hier der einzige
ist der sich hat impfen lassen und das
nur weil er eine arbeitserlaubnis für
israel will und israel lässt nur
geimpfte ran so ist es ausgerechnet der
erklärte feind israel der dafür sorgt
dass die impfbereitschaft nicht völlig
stagniert noch haben die ärzte hoffnung
dass das gesundheitssystem nicht
kollabiert aber dafür muss sich dringend
etwas ändern
danke für diese eindrücke und
einschätzung aus dem gazastreifen an
erfasst
als bischof kämpfte desmond tutu mit
nelson mandela gegen das rassistische
apartheidsystem in südafrika tutto wurde
sowie später auch mandela dafür mit dem
friedensnobelpreis geehrt und prägte den
begriff der regenbogen nation heute ist
desmond tutu im alter von 90 jahren
gestorben
weltweit ist die trauer groß sandra
teils über die ikone des anti apartheid
kampfes des mito
desmond tutu kämpfte gegen die
ungerechtigkeit der apartheid vor allem
dafür wurde er respektiert und geliebt
und immer wieder zeigte er mut so wie
hier als er verhinderte dass ein
angeblicher verräter gelöscht wird der
amerikaner wurde eine ikone des
widerstands
ich will ein südafrika in dem schwarz
weiß gelb und grün zusammen arbeiten am
inn ein wenn man das revolution nennt
dann bin ich dafür
1975 wird tut uhr erster schwarzer dekan
in johannesburg elf jahre später
anglikanische erzbischof in kapstadt
tutu nutzte seine ämter er machte die
welt auf die ungerechtigkeit der
apartheid aufmerksam dafür wurde ihm
mehrfach zeitweise der pass entzogen
1984 bekam er aber auch internationale
anerkennung den friedensnobelpreis
als funktionär übernahme die wohl
schwierigste aufgabe den vorsitz der
wahrheits und versöhnungskommission die
die menschenrechtsverletzungen der
apartheid aufarbeiten opfer und täter
miteinander versöhnen wollte tutto
nannte sich selbst einen quälgeist immer
wieder kritisierte er auch die eigene
regierung wir haben die möglichkeit
dafür zu sorgen dass keines unserer
kinder unter einem baum lernen muss das
ist eine schande
ich spreche hier nicht über politik
sondern als ein alter
desmond tutu war das moralische gewissen
südafrikas seine stimme wird fehlen
sorgen kennt man auch im paradies etwa
auf den seychellen die klimakrise
bedroht die weltberühmten malerischen
traumstrände der kleine staat im
indischen ozean vor der ostküste afrikas
besteht aus 115 inseln noch wenn der
meeresspiegel steigt und so holt sich
das wasser stück für stück kostbares
land unser korrespondent normen und man
hat auf den seychellen menschen
getroffen die um jeden zentimeter
kämpfen
die schönheit ist noch da aber sie ist
ein bisschen verblasst korallenbleiche
zu hohe schwankende temperaturen lassen
die unterwasserwelt leiden
forscherinnen haben metallgestell
versenkt die mit elektro impulsen
versorgt werden das regt die korallen
zum wachstum an der mensch versucht
gerade zu biegen was er angerichtet hat
es sieht wirklich ganz gut aus die
fische haben unsere neuen korallen
inzwischen angenommen sie putzen sogar
unsere anlage das gesamtbild sieht jetzt
schon sehr viel gesünder aus das ist ein
erfolg für
hoffnung also für das paradies zumindest
an dieser stelle aber die seychellen
sind auch zu lande bedroht der
meeresspiegel steigt trägt sand ab
gefährdet küsten ganze insel straßen
mussten verlegt werden häuser verlassen
und mancher idyllische strand mit
betonklötzen und steinen befestigt mehr
als die hälfte der 115 seychellen inseln
sei vom untergang bedroht warnt der
präsident
es geht für uns um zu überleben um
unsere existenz
wir spüren wir die auswirkungen dessen
was in den industrienationen geschieht
womit die ihre milliarden profite
erwirtschaften in beim klimawandel sind
wir hier nur die opfer
[Musik]
frei von verantwortung ist wohl kaum
jemand der tourismus jedenfalls ist auch
kein unschuldiges geschäft eine reise zu
den perlen des indischen ozeans einmal
paradies und zurück das wünschen sich
eben viele
und die gesamte dokumentation über das
leben im bedrohten paradies können sie
morgen sehen direkt im anschluss an die
heute sendung um 19 uhr 25
zurück nach deutschland
bundesaußenminister in bernburg will die
regeln für rüstungsexporte verschaffen
nachdem die alte bundesregierung gerade
noch einen neuen rüstungsexport rekord
aufgestellt hat will die neue koalition
die rüstungspolitik nun auf den
prüfstand stellen das sagte beck der dpa
spd grüne und fdp wollen vor allem
rüstungslieferungen in länder außerhalb
von eu und nato eindämmen dazu zählt
auch ägypten dass dieses jahr erneut
einen spitzenplatz unter den
empfängerländern einnimmt
das jahr neigt sich dem ende zu zeit zu
schauen was sich
2022 gesetzlich ändert von plastiktüten
verbot bis zur erhöhung des mindestlohns
bürotisch mit hat die wichtigsten punkte
für sie zusammengefasst
2022 steigt der mindestlohn gleich
zweimal zum jahreswechsel von 9 eur 60
pro stunde auf 9 eur 82 zum ersten juli
auf 10 eur 45 die regierung plant ein
gesetz um ihn auf 12 euro anzuheben
auszubildende erhalten im ersten
lehrjahr künftig mindestens 585 euro
neues gibt es auch beim rezept
arztpraxen müssen rezepte für gesetzlich
versicherte künftig als qr code
ausstellen sofern technisch möglich
übergangsweise gilt auch das rosa papier
rezept noch
die deutsche post erhöht im neuen jahr
die preise
standardbriefe kosten künftig 85 cent
bei postkarten steigt das porto von 60
auf 70 cent
ab januar wird die pfandpflicht
ausgeweitet so waren beispielsweise
frucht und gemüsesäfte bisher
ausgenommen für alle getränke dosen und
einwegflaschen aus kunststoff sind dann
25 cent pfand fällig
der griff zur zigarette wird teurer für
eine packung mit 20 stück werden
durchschnittlich zehn cent mehr
tabaksteuer fällig ab mitte des jahres
kräftig steuer erstmals auch bei
substanzen für e zigaretten tabak für
wasserpfeifen wird mit einer
zusatzsteuer belegt
ab nächstem jahr darf der handel
standard einkaufstüten nicht mehr
anbieten so wie diese hier erlaubte
bleiben dünne für obst und gemüse sowie
stabilere mehrweg taschen
am zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag gerollt
und fliegt dabei wenn was es alles
passiert am sport es gab eine faustdicke
überraschung in der handball-bundesliga
der unumstrittene tabellenführer sc
magdeburg kassierte nach 16 siegen in
der liga und insgesamt 28 pflichtspielen
ohne niederlage die erste pleite bei
verfolger flensburg-handewitt die
verschärften coroner regelungen noch
nicht in kraft und so können die rund
3000 lassen den zuschauer im norden
allen überraschende ungefährdeten sieg
ihrer mannschaft im spitzenspiel
bejubeln flensburg zeitweise sechs tore
in führung weil die außenspieler des
vizemeisters ihre chancen nutzen und
torhüter pohritzsch mit zahlreichen
paraden glänzen magdeburg verkürzt den
rückstand in einem temporeichen spiel
zum schluss zwar noch auf drei tore die
erste saison niederlage können die gäste
jedoch nicht mehr abwenden 30 27 der
entstand die sg flensburg handewitt
sorgt vor der em pause wieder für
meisterschaft spannung in der handball
bundesliga
traditionell spielt die premier league
in england heute am sogenannten boxing
day wegen einer vielzahl an corona
fällen mussten allerdings drei partien
abgesagt werden das spiel des
tabellenführers manchester city gegen
leicester konnte stattfinden sogar vor
über 50.000 zuschauern im
city mit traumstart viel platz für de
bruyne die führung zehn minuten später
thielemanns hält laporte feld elfmeter
manchester marie zurück gegen seinen
ex-klub manchester drückt schmeichel vor
die füße von gündogan 30 kurz darauf
erneut foulelfmeter diesmal sterling zum
4 0 nach 25 minuten nach der pause
anschlusstreffer madison und kurz darauf
steht es sogar nur noch 4 zu 3 i hated
show dorf die prompte antwort des
tabellenführers laporte zum 5 und erneut
nach ecke sterling zum 6 3 endstand
von city bleibt souverän tabellenführer
ghana dankeschön wenige tage vor
silvester schauen jetzt nochmal auf 20
21 zurück auf die bilder die dieses jahr
geprägt haben die korona pandemie etwa
impfen
impfen ist es immer wieder mal war der
impfstoff nicht da mal die impfwilligen
erschütternde bilder im sommer bei der
flutkatastrophe im aartal
und dem überstürzten abzug aller
westlichen truppen aus afghanistan
bis zum machtwechsel in deutschland und
dem ende der ära merkel
es gab aber auch faszinierende bilder
wie beim vulkanausbruch auf der
ferieninsel la palma
das album 20 21 die bilder eines jahres
gleich im anschluss an unsere sendung
jetzt aber noch das wetter am montag
kann es zwischen nordsee und erzgebirge
regnen dann besteht glatteisgefahr
ab dem nachmittag regnet es im südwesten
die höchstwerte liegen zwischen minus
zwei bis plus zehn grad die kommenden
tage bringen viel regen und sehr milde
luft
das heute die man ich wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend an diesem
zweiten weihnachtstag wir sehen
[Musik]